Nikki Haley is now not the only 2024
Republican primary candidate to fail at
answering the question how is it that
you were going to defeat Donald Trump in
this primary what are the differences
between you and Donald Trump in this
primary a South Carolina Republican
senator Tim Scott who announced his
candidacy uh which is completely dead on
arrival earlier this week he now was
asked on Fox News Trump's crushing the
polls how is that exactly will you
defeat him and Senator Tim Scott failed
or was unwilling to answer the question
in any real way I'm going to play the
clip for you he uses words I recognize
they're all English words that I can
Define I've heard these words before yet
he's not actually communicating anything
he either has no plan or he doesn't plan
to defeat Trump and maybe he's running
for vice president I don't exactly know
the strategy if there even is a strategy
here's Tim Scott and this is not a
winning strategy in the sense that it is
not a strategy at all have to go back to
the former president because his lead is
so mighty
how do you take on someone who literally
fights to fight I mean I know you saw
2016 you saw 2020. Donald Trump is a
master at it what's your game plan
I can't find the simple one I'm running
for president United States and I plan
to be the nominee so the good news is
for the American people you will have a
stark contrast between me and the rest
of the field I look forward to being the
messenger that actually adds to our
party without diluting our conservative
values okay was there an answer in there
the answer is no there was not
uh listen you um you how exactly are you
going to be doing brain transplant
surgery in five years when you're not in
medical school we don't have brain
transplant surgery as a procedure that
is done like how exactly are you going
to do it well listen five years are
going to go by and then I'm going to be
doing brain transplants oh wow I guess I
never thought about it that way that's
the absurdity of what Tim Scott is
saying here you're losing by 80. I mean
the numbers are completely ridiculous
how are you going to defeat Trump here
how are you going to get the support you
need I'm going to be the party's nominee
wow pretty amazing that you plan to do
that using words I recognize that don't
mean anything now I got a couple emails
from people saying what he means is I
plan to be Trump's vice president I
don't actually plan to win I'm really
running for vice president and the way
I'm going to do that is similar to the
Nikki Haley technique which is present
myself as an alternative
but don't really attack Trump
make it this kind of mild like well my
identity is different
um and then be there when it's time for
Donald Trump to choose his vice
president very low energy stuff um a
couple other clips from Tim Scott
yesterday on Fox News here he um is
asked about uh contrast to other
candidates he says he's not going to
talk about other candidates it's going
to make it tough to win my friend I'm
not going to focus on the other
candidates in this race I'm going to
focus on word we should keep the focus
it's on the American people too many of
us spend too much time talking about
ourselves there you go he's not going to
talk about himself or the other
candidates that's going to make it
really hard to win I mean I don't I
don't know how else to say it it will be
an extraordinarily difficult task to
convince more than 50 percent of
Republican primary voters to to choose
you over the other candidates when
you're polling one percent by not
talking about yourself nor the other
candidates that's really really really
strange and then he says the left is
quaking in their boots he keeps
repeating this I haven't heard one
person on the left say they're afraid of
Tim Scott here's what we're seeing the
radical left is quaking in their boots
because when an African-American
conservative who believes in the future
of this nation stands up to be counted
they push back that's a good sign we're
on the right message so I guess he's
saying the left is scared of him because
he's black which is a really strange
thing to say now that being said is he
going to run an identity campaign and
what I mean by that is Nikki Haley the
only things she really was willing to
draw a distinction with Trump on
seem to be that she's a woman and she's
younger and she's a person of color
maybe Tim Scott's plan is the same which
is I'm younger and I'm black I don't
know the problem is there's no evidence
that the Maga Republican party is
looking for a black candidate and I've
already explained to you why that is and
and that's gone back for a while so not
exactly a winning proposition and in the
meantime right-wing media and some uh
right-wing elected officials are
starting to do the mildly homophobic
attacks on Tim Scott and you might be
saying I didn't even know Tim Scott was
gay I don't know that he is but let's
talk about that next
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a
12-month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it and you'll get
15 off when you go to boncharge.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down down below